Standing next to me is
Winefred Winefred Riley.
She is a psychotherapist specializing in
marital therapy and relationship issues
in a private practice in Berkeley,
California.
In her 35 years of clinical practice,
she has treated hundreds of couples
who are convinced they're headed for
divorce.
Ms. Riley has been a guest lecture on
marriage and sexuality and her writing has
appeared on the Huffington Post,
the good men project x chain
and her blog speak of marriage.
I'm so excited that we get to
hear Winifred Riley. Thanks.
Thank you so much.
So I'm going to start first.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm going to start first by
telling you this personal story.
So my husband and I were married
early on a Sunday morning.
By late that afternoon we were in the
car driving down one o one to spend a few
days down in big Sur.
So our friends had painted,
just married across the back of our car.
So as we're driving along,
people are honking and waving
and giving the thumbs up.
And then this guy in the pickup truck
comes on pulling on up to our car and he's
honking from my husband
to roll down the window.
And then at about 75 miles an hour,
this guy leans across the cab of
his truck and yells out the window,
don't do it.
So I there,
I married what, maybe five hours,
six hours, and I'm thinking,
Nah,
that'll never be us.
Not not the business of yelling out
of the car, window and newlyweds,
but the idea that we would
be disgruntled or unhappy,
it never occurred to me now you'd think
that it would've known better given my
work, given that I'm a
marriage and family therapist.
I mean you think I would have been better
prepared in some way for what marriage
would be,
but actually I was as naive,
an unprepared as my clients.
I had ideas that were fairly useless.
Like we have so much in
common and we're so in love.
How hard could this be?
So here's what a client of mindset
on the eve of her third anniversary.
Yeah,
I know marriage takes work.
Everybody knows that I was prepared
for that and I knew we'd have our
difficulties,
but I never ever imagined that the
biggest difficulty in my life would be my
husband George.
So I'm here today to talk about my book.
It takes one to tango.
I'm going to talk about why marriage is
hard and I'm going to tell you a little
bit of my personal story,
how I changed my own marriage by taking
a leadership role and how you can create
a vibrant and satisfying relationship too.
So the question is,
why is marriage so hard? Well, here,
marriage puts two people into a small
space with the expectation of keeping them
there for a lifetime and then says,
good luck.
Marriage doesn't come with
a guidebook or a roadmap.
And none of us come in with
all the skills that we need.
Many of us have had terrible role models.
We've had parents who fought to the
death or hated each other and finally
divorced,
or we had over idealized romantic role
models like grandparents who were married
75 years in swore.
They never had one single argument now.
And then there you are in your honeymoon
on the third day and you're ready to
kill each other. So you've completely
blown it right out of the gate.
Then we also have these mistaken ideas,
like marriage is harder,
marriage shouldn't be hard,
or people who fight should get a divorce
or those people look really happy.
What's wrong with us then? You know,
so we have the negative role miles
and there was a confusion about the
difference between marriage and courtship.
Courtship is that wonderful drunk on
love beginning phase where it's all about
sameness and loveliness and you just
can't believe that you finally found
someone so perfect, someone so much
like you with so much in common.
And unfortunately courtship doesn't last.
And many people really do think that's,
that's what relationships are.
So when court ends,
they just move on to the next one.
Or when marriage gets difficulty or the
long, the longer relationships start to,
they start to struggle. People
think, Nah, I better move on.
So the, so when people struggle and
they find marriage to be difficult,
what I want people to know
is that nothing is wrong.
It's just that marriage is a really
tough teacher and we all have plenty to
learn, but many of us don't like
the idea of being beginners.
We think somehow we're supposed
to be good at everything,
even without any practice at all.
No.
My graduate school training mimicked
some of these myths about marriage that
that were not particularly helpful,
but worse.
It seemed to me the trouble that people
had in marriage be more of a pathology,
sort of an aberration,
more than the norm.
But I was thinking there are some really
lovely people that I see in my practice
and my husband and I were
not preparing exactly crazy,
but we were going at it in
ways that didn't make sense.
So I thought something
is wrong with this idea.
So I decided to figure out
why and in order to do that,
I decided to turn myself
into a marriage expert. Now,
back then, none of this existed. I
couldn't just sit at my computer.
Well actually I didn't even have a
computer back then and I couldn't just sit
down and Google.
Why is my husband driving me crazy?
What am I supposed to do? It was none
of that. So I went to the bookstore.
I had to,
you know,
I went books and I took workshops and
trainings and went to conferences.
And here's the most
interesting thing that I found.
It pretty much turned
everything I understood about
marriage and relationships
upside down.
So most of us think that marriage is
about agreement and consensus about
compromising and meeting halfway.
It's our need for consensus
that's driving us crazy.
We need this agreement, we need this
validation. We need somebody to say,
yes, I hear you. I agree with you.
I perfectly understand you. Oh yes.
What you're saying makes perfect
sense and yes, let's do it your way.
But of course it's this, you
know, of course we all like that.
I mean everybody wants validation.
And what I like to say is that validation
is a perfectly fine thing to want and
it's a really dangerous thing to need.
So here's essentially
what it comes down to.
We need to learn how to
disagree, not agree. Now,
I'm not saying that we have to fight
all the time and that that's the key to
happiness.
I'm just saying that what we have to do
is we need to learn to effectively deal
with being two different people.
This was 180 degrees off of everything
that I believed up until then,
but somehow it made perfect sense to me.
I didn't know how to apply it to my life,
but I knew that I was onto something.
So let's consider this quote from Einstein
central to the advancement of human
civilization is the
spirit of open inquiry.
We must not only learn to tolerate
our differences, we must welcome that,
welcome them as the
richness and diversity,
which can lead to true intelligence.
So I read this quote and I'm in a
workshop for therapists and we're,
we're working with how to
deal with our most impossible,
difficult couples.
So I thought immediately of this
couple up, or Bruce and Cindy,
they were my couple from hell.
They fought about everything. They
just, you're there the corner.
And they couldn't decide, you know,
if they're just taking a walk,
whether they should go right or left.
So I try to imagine die hard,
Vegan Bruce,
welcoming as rich and diverse,
his wife's Cindy's interest in any
hamburger when this pi would not even wear
leather shoes.
And what I realize is that's the point.
We don't have to get the person senior,
never going to agree on anything.
And the good news is I didn't,
we didn't actually have
to make them agree.
But here's, here's one of the
pieces of trouble with consensus.
Okay.
So have you ever noticed that your
version and your spouse's version sound
nothing alike?
Have you thought that maybe you're
living in alternate realities,
parallel realities on a good day.
So here's how I observed
this in my office people.
So somebody's there and they're
starting to talk and they say, you know,
and this thing happened and that they
have near Portner moves like some micro
movement. Why brow little suddenly
happens in what, what? And they,
there was a completely riveted,
they can't finish a sentence.
They can't complete a thought. And
they say, see, this is what I mean.
We can't talk about X.
I'm not allowed to bring up why.
And I say, why not? Who made these rules?
And so if you want to
know who made these roles,
I'm going to ask you to take a
minute and I want you to think about,
imagine,
remember the two of you back in the
early days of your relationship.
There you are.
You're in Starbucks sharing cafe lattes.
Maybe you're actually drinking one
tea with two straws and you're,
you're planning your weekend away
romantic the first trip to the country.
And now meanwhile,
in some smokey back room,
your people and your partners,
people are back there negotiating
the terms of your relationship.
Okay, fine. Uh,
I won't question how many times a day she
has to talk to her mother. Okay, fine.
And she's just not going to bring up what
the cost of those club level seats are
at the ballpark and all right.
Really? Ah, okay. They'll never,
ever, ever talk about sex.
So this gets signed into law.
They shake hands. Meanwhile you're
out there, you know, having a Lark,
you have no idea that these are actually
the rules that will confine you.
They will define you,
they will make you miserable.
They will make you feel like you were
living in a box until you have the
strength and stamina to change them.
Now sad about courtship,
about courtship being about all
things lovely and wonderful.
These rules,
you made these roles back in the beginning
when the goal was to keep the peace,
to fall in love,
to preserve your bond,
to keep your partner essentially from
thinking you're completely awful and
deciding to leave you. So all of
these things are hidden, but you,
you make these rules and you will
have to live with them. So that's,
that's what courtship is.
And so here's marriage.
Marriage is essentially about
the rest of your life together.
You can't keep up the facade of,
of not being yourself when you,
when you're,
when you're in a long relationship.
So marriage is really about coming to
terms with the fact that you're two
different people that you want
different things that you liked,
different things that some of the things
you're going to want are going to clash
with what your partner has in mind.
Now,
this is really,
really important.
We have to figure out how to deal
with this, our differences with grace,
and in order to do this,
you're going to have to learn
how to stand on your own.
This is crucial.
This is the whole,
this is the whole point that I wrote
and this is why I wrote this book.
If you can't stand on your own,
if you can't take a position,
you're never going to challenge the rules.
You're not going to live your life.
You're not going to like your partner.
You're not going to like how you feel.
You will have compromised
your core values.
You will have sunk below your own
bottom line. You will be fearful.
You will find yourself spending
a year saying things like,
we're not allowed to do this
and I'm not allowed to do that.
You're going to feel trapped.
You are going to blame your spouse.
If you,
if you imagine yourself one
year, five year, 10 years,
I'm married almost 40 years,
find yourself all the way down the line.
You won't even know. You would've
been able to recognize yourself.
You will have turned yourself into a
pretzel of accessibility and you won't,
and you won't be able to standard.
Why this is important is that you have
to realize what's at stake. You've,
you've sacrificed your eye for your weed.
And in order to be happily married,
to be in a satisfying relationship,
we have to be as connected to
ourselves as we are to our spouse.
If you can't do that,
what's at stake is your vitality,
your wellbeing,
and really even possibly
your entire relationship.
So here's where my
personal story comes in.
I come home from this workshop I've taken,
I've gotten this new
idea and I'm ecstatic.
I'd finally figured out why my husband
and I are fighting like a couple of
junkyard dogs. I figure
this is it. I've got it.
So I come home and I'm all
excited and I said, essentially,
honey, this is the greatest
thing that's ever happened.
I'm going to dismantle our entire marriage
right down to the rafters and we're
going to remodel this whole
thing while we live in it.
And I'm going to be the architect
and the carpenter. So I has been,
you know,
we didn't embrace the,
all of these ideas with quite the
relish that I did. And you know,
pretty much what he said was, I pretty
much think our marriage is fine as it is.
So I know it didn't deter me. I
decided no, I'm going to keep at it.
I knew that this was right. You know,
but, but then actually, so to be honest,
what he actually said after,
I think our marriage is fine as it is,
he actually said you went to a workshop
for the weekend and you came back
brainwashed and you are essentially,
you're going to save our marriage.
You were about to destroy it.
So I mean,
I can't blame him for thinking this.
I mean,
I'm seeing things like in order to
be close, we have to be separate.
In order to stop fighting, we have to
disagree. You know, this is so many,
could be sense. And so I
can, I can understand. So,
and here's the other thing.
I was pretty much,
here's the picture.
If this is exactly what I was like,
I came home like a lunatic.
Zelle, I'm, I'm, I'm, you know, I,
I knew that this was right,
but there was some way in which I
couldn't actually sell it to him.
So I kept trying out my good ideas
and books to read and things to do.
And, and it was, and it was, you know,
it's like a door to door salesman
trying to sell a reluctant housewife,
a new vacuum cleaner. I don't really
need this. Mine works just fine.
So I was about to give up and then I
realized that maybe going about this all
wrong,
I realized that my,
my,
the instructions,
what I was going by was that
you have to stand on your own.
You have to take risks.
But what I was doing was he was exactly
the opposite of what I needed to do.
I was trying to get my husband's buyin.
It was,
it was as if I was saying,
honey,
I can't very well stand and be
separate from you if you don't join me.
I can't take the lead
if you don't come along.
And that was when I realized that this
business of changing my marriage was
going to be a whole lot harder and a
little more complicated than I had first
anticipated.
I realized then that if I was
going to change my marriage,
I was going to have to change it myself.
So I didn't have,
I didn't have any real,
um,
real rules for how to do this.
But, but, but this, these are
the principles that I had.
You can't change your partner.
You have to take risks.
You have to challenge the rules
that can find you and frustrate you.
You have to recognize and accept that
this is not a kind of a beeline to change.
You're going to have to learn by falling
seven times and standing up a eight.
And most of all,
you're going to need to focus on yourself.
Well,
I decided that focusing
on myself was the best,
was the best place to begin.
So instead of focusing on all of the
ways in which he was contributing toward
difficulties, when focusing on myself,
I discovered a handful of things.
I'm a stubborn,
is my husband.
I'm as likely to start a fight as he is.
I am maybe even less
likely to allow it to end.
I will be willing to fight about anything
as ridiculous and stupid as it might
be, as long as I have to end up
being right. But the worst thing,
the most painful observation that I
had was that I realized that I have the
staying power of a
dandelion under pressure.
I would just crumble.
And it,
it didn't really match my sense of
myself who I am out in the world.
But somehow at home there were these
ways that our interactions would switch,
you know, would just make me dissolve. So,
so I decided that further than
just this focus, which helped,
I learned how to stop being pulling
my end of the tug of war rope.
What I realized that I needed to do was
I needed to pick this most frustrating
mind boggling interaction that
I would have with my husband.
It's what I refer to as
our loopy logic fight here.
Way kind of start with, we didn't
matter what we were talking about it,
but within a short period of time he's
throwing things in from left field and
right. I'd be saying, wait, wait, wait a
minute. Where are we talking about shoes?
Wait a second, I thought we were
talking about and then it's what,
what's going on?
And I would just lose my ability
to think he was very good.
I really have died by or competence.
He was terrific and I would make me lose.
It would just,
I feel like I was losing my mind.
So what I began doing was experimenting
with what would it take for me to
maintain my thoughts,
to feel like I'm staying in one piece.
So I tried deep breathing and I tried
counting backwards and I tried writing
down points that I wanted to make,
but none of that worked.
So then one day I decided
to take a physical step back
then I noticed I was able to maintain
my thinking better but not very well.
So I took another step back
and then I experimented.
I come back in the room and I'd look,
I would just lose it in about six seconds
I come back out of the room and so I
did this. Honestly, people say, how
long did it take? It took a year.
It took a year for me
to actually be able to,
to stand there and this
is how it happened.
One day in the middle of
one of our stupid go rounds,
I realized I didn't have to leave the
room there I was an and it was like
suddenly this words for like snowflakes
falling through the air and I was
perfectly calm and I knew what I thought
and I knew what I wanted to say and it
was like,
like being popping outside of the pull
of gravity and just floating free through
space.
And so here's what I'm
going to ask for you to do.
I would like for you,
here's my question.
Yeah.
What experience do you have?
What's,
what is it like for you?
What experience do you have
where you lose yourself?
Where what you want it feels out of reach.
Where what goes on makes your head spin
and frustrates you or makes you shut
down or cry or blow up.
What one situation would
you like to master?
So I'd like you to just take
a minute and write it down.
One way to think about it is this,
instead of x,
I want to do y instead of blowing up.
I'm wondering remain calm
instead of crying when I'm angry,
I want to be able to hold
my thoughts together.
I want to be able to express myself.
Now.
In order for you to do this,
you're going to have to do two things.
You're going to have to give up trying
to change your partner and I mean really
give it up. I don't mean just lip
service. No, no pun intended there.
I didn't mean lip service to the idea of
secretly believing your partner should
change.
People come in and they,
it's like they bring in a broken toaster
to the fix it shop in my office and
they just,
it's like here I finally brought,
I'm bringing my situation to an expert.
I've tried to fix my partner and here
it goes and so it's not like that.
The thing about marriage
is that it's a choice.
We can stay with our
partner or we can leave,
but if we're going to stay,
we have to really, we have,
we have one of two choices.
We can,
we can be completely driven nuts by our
partner or we can figure out what we're
going to do with ourselves.
So the other thing you're
going to have to do,
you're going to have to totally
give up the, it takes to paradigm.
You're going to have to throw out all
this stuff about fairness and needing both
partners to work as a team and change.
See,
this is one of the things that
surprise me in my own marriage,
that then as I was busy
focusing on myself,
my husband was actually
changing in ways all on his own.
He was calming down and occasionally he
was even the more levelheaded arguing
when we would get into
something. He, he, you know,
one day he completely surprised me.
I came home and I was,
I know I came home to make lunch and left
all his stuff all over the counter and
the plate and the fork and that,
all of that stuff.
And I was immediately incensed and um,
and so weeks we started
that into it. Oh, like,
well what a nice way for you to come
home and say hello. Well, you know, I'm,
I only have 15 minutes and I have to deal
with your math back and forth and back
and forth. We went and then, then
he stopped and he said, okay,
hold on a minute. Let's
back up. So in other words,
you come home in a rush
and complain about my mass.
I get defensive and you feel despair.
You said about right?
And I said, uh, yeah, now I really,
I was about to fall
over. And he said, yeah,
I can see that.
And then he began to clean up.
So what happens when you stop focusing
on your partner and you focus on
yourself? That was what he did. He began,
he was focused on me and then
he was focused on himself.
So you're going to have to
completely give up the one, the, the,
the two to Tango Paradigm
in order for this to work.
Now here's the interesting
thing that people say, you know,
in business people, people you know,
are, are impressed with leadership.
They call leaders decoding, being an
innovator. They, you know, they say,
you know, you're, you're a twin center.
But when I suggest that people have
to take it in their own marriage,
they think that I'm centrally telling
them that they're going to have to be some
sort of doormat.
So I promise you,
I'm asking you to roll over and play
dead or give up on the things that are
important to you or just live with
conditions that you can't stand.
I'm really suggesting that you recognize
the power of being a leader for change
in your relationship.
And,
and it really is going to start with that
one thing that I'm asking you to look
at.
The one thing that you can change,
the one thing that you can control and,
and,
and don't be surprised if it takes
a long time for you to master that,
that one thing that I asked you
to do. It's an incredibly, it's,
it's so much more empowering than
waiting for your partner to change.
So, you know, in, and, and
basically what I, you know,
what I want you to understand is that
you have more power than you think.
If you're skeptical,
you're not alone.
I mean really I'm asking you to let go
of one of the most cherished beliefs that
people have to change as a team that
that it's not worth doing if your spouse
doesn't join you.
So I'm really just asking
you to take the challenge,
challenge yourself.
The goal is not here to turn you into
a little island of self sufficiency.
It's about turning you into a partner
who's capable of change is capable of
leadership.
One person must take the
first step in change.
My invitation to you is why
not let that person be you.
Thank you.
I love this so much.
And one of the chapters in almost every
chapter there was something where I had
to put it down and think about it,
but almost everything in chapter
six when it says it happens once,
what happens once you calm down?
And that for me has been in my marriage
and very difficult thing to do is just
to calm down because I was high pressure.
Yes.
Under the same impression or feelings
that you were talking about where we have
to do this together.
We have to agree,
and my husband really likes for me
to agree with him. And so it's very,
it caused not surprising kinds of issues.
So, um, but calming down,
it's just such a great
thought and a great, yeah.
Honest and it's not something
that's easy to do. You know,
when you're really upset and somebody
says to you, calm down. I mean,
how useless is that? Right. You
know, so it actually has to happen.
It has to happen from inside and it
really is another one of those kind of try
this and try that. You
know, like I was saying,
in order to stay present in my
loopy logic fight, you know,
I tried counting,
I tried digging my fingernails in my hand.
I tried planting my feet,
you know, it really just,
it ended up being that I
needed the physical distance.
And little did I know that what I was
doing at that point was kind of calming
down my,
my neocortex.
I was staying in that little sliver of
reasonable nets while the kind of flood
of the whole rest of my brain was taking
over and acting like it was some kind
of emergency and that I'm in on
page one 31 you talk about how,
and this,
this is for me a revolutionary
thought for most people.
It takes some time to grow comfortable
with the idea of being responsible for
comforting ourselves when
we're disappointed our
hurt and somewhat longer to
discover its benefits.
And you'd recognize the point of self
soothing with your children. Yes. We all,
you know, yeah. We want them to self
soothe so that we can get a night's sleep.
Yes.
And to self sooth ourselves
as a partner in the marriage.
Yeah. I mean if you think about
it, you're in the middle of a,
of a thing with your partner.
If you're reliant on them to be soothing,
you mean they're busy,
they're brain is lit up at that moment.
And so where are you going to do
go into some sort of free fall?
I mean you have to actually settle down
and tell yourself I'm really going to be
okay. Well, one of my clients
had a wonderful phrase.
He said that the thing that would help
him the most was that when he got anxious,
he would remind himself.
He would say, okay,
I might get her here but
I'm not going to die.
That was his self soothing
and so we find something, uh,
what are some of your
suggestions? Okay, well like I
said, you can breathe, you can,
I think you have to start with,
with the,
the novel idea that
it's actually your job.
And I think that's a big beginning
part. It, you know, being,
being able to lean on each other and
being together. Like I said, we're not,
this is not about being a little island,
it's just about,
it's like it stays to be
able to lean on each other,
but you have to be able
to stand on your feet,
especially when you're not agreeing.
You know,
you can't lean on somebody else while,
while they're agitated or
holding their position.
So you can breathe,
you can talk yourself down,
you can take breaks, you can say,
hold on, I'm just getting flooded.
I'm going to step out.
I'm not suggesting that you
come back two days later. Um,
you know what I'm saying? Just five
minutes. Quiet your brain down.
So it really is an experiment.
Uh,
sometimes there are issues that
are so hot to deal with that you,
you pick them up tomorrow.
Okay,
that's great.
Um,
did you want to ask a question and we
have stories of questions right here.
Okay.
I'm going to read the Dory questions and
feel free to add as many as you would
like.
And there it is anonymous.
So the first question we have is how to
convince your partner to go to couple's
therapy and is it helpful to do it alone?
Great.
I love that question.
You can't convince or persuade
someone to do something that they're
uncomfortable with. You can ask.
It's actually your job to ask.
I mean, nobody is going to advocate
for you except you. But you know,
there are reasons people don't want to
go to couple's therapy. They, you know,
they think it's a first step
toward divorce. They're fearful.
They think that, um, things
were fine. They are, uh,
what's, you know, don't walk the
boat, um, or the, or the or, you know,
or they just don't believe in
it. And so I, it's, it's this,
it's the one to tango principal.
If there's something important to you,
go on your own.
Take the lead.
I do work with some people by
themselves without their partner. Uh,
and so a good couple of
therapists will actually help you,
not just take your side. It's not that
helpful means it's lovely. But if you,
if you're talking about
nonsense in your relationship,
you actually have had somebody
who, who can, you know,
not just commiserate with you but
actually help you take charge of yourself.
So, you know, I think sometimes
what people, I, it's very,
it's kind of a sort of seems obvious.
Uh,
just you can start by saying,
this is really important to me.
Uh,
and I'd like you to go at
least try it once and uh,
but really go by yourself, go by
yourself. It a lot can happen if he,
if you don't just go there to complain,
but you go there to say, like, I did,
you know, saying, oh wait,
I'm as big of a hothead. Oh,
here's my contribution to the
difficulty and I want help with that.
What are some of the steps one
can take when they're screaming,
name calling as well as verbal
abuse in the relationship,
but the partner refuses
to stop this behavior.
Or the partner says it will stop if the
partner does such and such a few change.
Okay. Well, all right, so, so if
somebody is screaming and yelling,
I differentiate this from, you know,
where there's physical violence.
So let's just take that off of
this off the table. It's just,
it's kind of bevel on it, your house. Um,
I think the surprising thing is
for you to be able to remain calm.
I learned this from my
son's kindergarten teacher.
The room would be chaotic and
she was a whore. Her voice,
she would get really quiet and the
energy in the room would change. Now,
if your spouse is off the rails,
the last immune or it could be able
to reason with him or her anyway.
And so I suggest you sit
down and be a witness. Also.
You don't have to argue every single
point. I mean, we don't, you know,
you don't have to argue.
If somebody is saying the earth is flat,
you don't actually have to say, we'll
actually hear here is his wife's round.
You have to calm down.
You also might want to try
with a really nasty, uh,
spouse, uh, saying, you know,
w
do you, do you actually think I can
hear you when you talk like that?
How about if we sit down?
What did you tell me what it is you
want you to understand or I don't really
have any idea why you get so frustrated.
Do you have any idea why you
totally lose it? You know,
that you start to become the ambassador
for sanity in a crazy situation.
It's least that's a start.
Okay.
Next question.
You talked about standing on your own
and taking a position in the same vein.
Do you think it's absolutely necessary
to spend time alone explicitly, um,
be single for many years
before being married? Well, I,
I wasn't. Um, and you know,
and so I was very young when I got
married and I, I, my sense of self, I,
Oh, I sure thought I was an adult,
but what I had lots of growing to do.
I think that that any coming
in at any phase in your life,
you're still going to meet challenges.
That whole list of why is marriage hard
that I talked about in the beginning,
it's still going to be difficult.
You know, you're going to think, oh,
I'm a really saying, well adjusted person.
I can, I can handle just about anything.
And then,
you know,
you put yourself in a small space with
somebody and you're going to just see,
we know all the little holes in
your, in, in yourself. You know,
this is quote a man. A man can be a fool
and not know it, but not if he's married,
you know, and a woman can be a fool
and not know it unless she's married.
And so,
um,
so I think that the more solid
and strong we are as as people,
the better is, but you're still
going to hit the trenches.
You still going to have to learn
how you live with this person when,
when agreeing to disagree,
it does not solve every problem.
Okay.
This next question is great.
Any advice for single people trying to
find or choose a partner and wanting to
make that relationship work?
Okay. Yeah. Well, you know,
it's the same as anyone.
Even a relationship.
Okay.
Be Clear about what you want.
Know as much about yourself
and be willing to be brave,
be willing to reveal yourself. I
have, I have clients who come in 20,
30 years down the line and,
and they've hidden so
many parts of themselves,
but they feel strangled and you know,
and so,
so the, the, the thing of when
you're looking for a relationship,
find somebody who's curious.
Find somebody who wants
to take an adventure. But,
but if it isn't going to
be a lark with anyone,
it's just not going to be
a walk in the park. But,
but somebody who's willing to laugh,
explore,
grow, um, you know, it's,
it, it, it's, it's, it helps.
And it's,
I appreciate what you said just
about knowing yourself because yeah,
it seems like no matter what,
how much you, you in, uh,
investigate the person or interview the
person or try to analyze the person.
It's always comes down to that when you
are on your side, that's to it. I mean,
it really is. You know, you can't, uh,
if you don't know what you want
and who you are and what you think,
if you have no connection to
your inner most reliable witness,
you're just going to be moving about and,
and you're not going to actually
be able to, to, to have it,
have your relationship go in
any direction. And so, you know,
it's not for sissies is what
say, you know, people say,
but longterm relationships.
Very true. And this one, this question is
about long distance relationships. Okay.
How would one approach this when a couple
is in a long distance relationship and
what are your thoughts on each
partner seeing a separate therapist?
Um, you know, so, so this may sound
like a kind of a jokey answer,
but therapy can be one of the worst
things you could do for your marriage.
I mean, there's statistics about
it, so it doesn't mean don't do it,
it's just that you will sometimes have,
you will, you therapists will take sides.
Um, you know, you're, you've got
two people. If you're focusing,
if you're doing relationship work,
not just in a work in a
work is a different thing
when you're doing it with an
individual therapy.
When you're doing relationship work.
I've actually worked with people where
someone flies in and I see them for,
you know, two or three hours and maybe
a couple of times in a short time.
And then we, and then they go back
and they do their own work that,
that in a long distance relationship,
some of the pressure is off. You know,
in the beginning I showed this cartoon
that was the definition of marriage is
two people in a row boat and they're
rowing in opposite directions.
So that's some of the stuff
that happens when you're,
when you're living together,
things heat up. But you know,
if you, um, you know, but, but
it's the same I suppose, you know,
any work, any, anytime
that you're together,
pay attention to yourself what
you want, you know, don't,
don't shy away from challenging things.
When you mentioned that therapy
isn't necessarily the best thing,
it reminded me of what you told us at
lunch that you had a therapist and a
recommended,
but something that wasn't, my therapist
said, oh, your husband and you know,
you're so frustrated, he's really
never going to to, you know,
really take a hold and, and grow. You
really should, you know, just move on.
Which was stunning. And,
and, and I actually stopped
that therapy pretty quickly,
uh, realizing that, you know,
I would've much rather somebody said,
you know what I what I'm saying to people,
well this is challenging. You know,
fast new seat belts. You don't
put on your work boots, get going,
see where you can go. It wasn't that
my husband was immune to change,
it just was, she used to come to, I'm
more content with things as they were.
So I came in with these ideas
for how to have it go better and,
and you know, and at this point he, he
would, he would not argue that this,
that our relationship is, you know, much,
much better because we
both basically grew up.
And that leaves me to a question
of how does one choose a therapist?
Because if you have a
therapist that is quick to say,
yeah, this isn't working out, you
guys should just get divorced.
I don't think you should allow
anyone to tell you to get divorced.
Remember what I said about
marriage being a choice.
You can stay with this
partner or you can leave,
but if you're going to stay,
you have two choices.
You can figure out what you're going to
do with yourself or you can allow that
person to drive you completely nuts.
And this business of figuring out what
to do with yourself is really pretty
extraordinary. There were a lot
of things we call, you know,
it's not just we calm down,
but I later in the book I
have a thing about what, what,
what some people discovered to be changed.
Like one person said to his wife is
just a busy person moving around,
always drove him really crazy.
And then you realize it's a little
bit like living near train tracks,
but people eventually stop hearing the
train and he's just stopped focusing on,
she was always running
around and doing stuff.
He figured out how to regulate his own
state and be peaceful in the midst of all
of her people coming and going and
calling, you know, so, so, you know,
rather than I need to be with you, you
need to slow down. He figured out how,
how to just maintain his
own shaping the context.
Next question,
how to get,
how to agree or to disagree
on parenting issues.
How we approach parenting if we are
coming from very different places.
This one, you know, I
could write an entire book.
This one is not a quick answer because
it's one of those things that you can't
have two philosophies.
You can't say we're never going to spank
the kids and somebody going to spank
the kids were, or you're never going
to do timeout or you're going to do,
you know? And so I think,
you know, I, I can't,
I can't actually give
this one a quick answer,
but it actually I think comes down to
needing to collaborate in some way but
more to be persuasive in terms of uh,
the seat. Okay. When you have to,
when you have two things and you're
only going to have one outcome,
the only way you're going to get anywhere
is it somebody is going to have to
yield, somebody is going to have to be
generous. They're going to have to say,
all right,
this is not my first choice.
But from a solid and strong place,
we'll do what you want.
We can't compromise. You can't
have, you know, half a time out.
You can't have one parent saying we
have no sugar in the house and the other
one, you know, feeding the
kid sugar. So or screen time.
I mean these issues you have to, it's,
it's, it's, it's sorta like this,
you're going to even move over here or
you're going to move over there and how
you do it I think does it
requires sense of self.
Don't expect these conversations that
happen quickly. Hang in there with it,
see if you can both come from the most
curious and generous places in yourself.
Thank you.
There are a couple more here.
How amplified is the,
it takes one to tango message when
one of the partners can't change much.
For example, Asperger's. Okay.
So I do work with couples like that and,
and um,
and so here's the,
here's the piece that,
that if the Asperger's person actually
work igniters is that there may be ways
that he or she isn't going to change
but can acknowledge that it drives their
spouse nuts.
That's one thing.
And then for the other spouse to give up
all hope of this person being different
and to,
and to make your own moves
and think your own thoughts.
You know, I work with one
couple where the guy would,
would be,
would begin every you'll
begin every answer or every
piece of a conversation was
begun with the word no. And he
eventually stopped, you know, she'd say,
I'd like to go to the moon. And
he'd say, no, I think, you know,
Pluto would be better. But every no is the
beginning of, so she eventually got to,
I can just ignore that word and I can,
you know,
I can listen and he big
and he actually did change.
I think people actually can
change or be not everything,
but I don't put a ceiling over
what's possible for people.
But I think you know,
you pick this person,
you know somewhat of what you're getting
and what you're not getting and you
have to figure out how to make
yourself happy in that context.
Okay.
Have you ever seen the technique you
describe work on a marriage that has
already failed,
where the partners are divorced
and separated or separated?
At which point,
um,
would you recommend as a professional
with experience giving up?
Okay. Well, if it's already
failed in your already divorced,
I mean I have seen people we married,
but I don't think that's
quite what you're asking.
So I'm going to answer a question of
like how far gone is too far gone.
Um, I actually in my book
opens with this quote,
it's a Turkish proverb that says,
no matter how far you have gone down
the wrong road, you can turn around.
So I never give up. Uh, it's not
my job to tell people, you know,
you can do it or you can't do it.
But I never give up.
I never put a ceiling over what's
possible for people. But here's the thing,
marriage is a choice.
If you want to try and make it a go,
I say you don't have anything to lose.
Give it your all. See what happens.
There is no guarantee as
to how it will come out.
But if you have even one shred of hope,
start working on your side of
it and don't and don't give up.
You still might not end up married, but
I like people to at least come out of it.
Being able to say, you know, I feel
as if I really did everything I could.
Okay.
This is our last question.
You mentioned getting, uh,
giving up the idea about 50,
50 fairness and working as a team.
How do you then balance day to
day obligations such as parenting,
working without being completely run
down or a bearing? Most of the weight?
Well, you know it's tricky because
this is a, this is a common concern,
especially for the person who feels like
they're already carrying more weight.
It's not, this is the, the, the Ma this,
this idea is not about how you should be
doing all of the cleaning and watching
all the kids and doing, you
know, and it's turning your,
turning cartwheels about everything.
It really is about.
So if you're in a situation where
your partner is not doing much,
this is a time where you actually
might need to really step forward.
And instead of saying, you know,
like what's wrong with you?
You might say this would be like what
I would say to somebody in my office.
So what do you tell yourself while you're
sitting there reading and your wife is
running around doing the dishes,
unloading the dishwasher and, and,
and juggling three children.
Like tell me how that makes sense to you.
And so you know,
you,
you want to find yourself in a position
where you're not working on changing
your spouse, but that doesn't mean you
know blooming where you're planted.
It means you, this is why I said
it's going to take gumption.
You're going to have to move toward
your difficulties and talk about them in
ways that figure out ways to talk
about them that are affective,
that aren't about
changing the other person,
but are really about coming
forward and being yourself. Great.
Thank you so much. Oh, it's
been really a pleasure.